Pete: Tell me a little bit about the team
that you're building here and why an engineer
would want to come and work at Tapad.
Well, that's an interesting question and of
course, it's not a hard one to answer actually.
We're looking to build a team with really,
really skilled engineers, both on the technical
side, but also on the team dynamics side.
We're looking for people that have already
a proven track record and that can come in,
get a problem, present it to them and then
start working on it with us and solving them.
If you want to attract really good developers,
then you typically have to give them something
that is interesting.
And Scala has no doubt about it caused a lot
of interest in the Java community and also
in other language communities and being slightly
esoteric is a good thing, if you want to attract
people.
Pete: Yeah, that's an interesting strategy.
And you have a unique perspective on repeatable
jobs versus jobs that require a lot of brain
power.
Tell me about that.
Dag: We have a slightly, I'm not sure if egalitarian
is the word here, but we don't hire first
rate and second rate programmers here, developers.
We expect everybody to perform on the same
level.
And this also means that we're not going to
have people coming in that have to do all
of the mundane tasks.
We want to make sure that you have a team
that everybody has to do simple things every
now and then, but if the simple thing is something
that's repeatable then you should be automated
instead of spending a time on that the next
time.
So, we automate the simple and we spend our
brain power on solving the harder and more
interesting problems.
There will always be a balance between the
really fun stuff, and then the more.
Well, most things are fun actually, but we
can never guarantee that every single day
will be super exciting.
Pete: That's great.
Dag: But I think when you put a lot of engineers,
really, really good ones into the same room,
they will always come up with really, really
good solutions, and they will be able to implement
them in a fraction of the time that a huge
team of less-skilled developers would.
So, and that's our, kind of founding principal
that applies the whole organization not only
to the development engineering team, this
applies to the whole company.
So, you will work with peers in product management
and in sales that are really awesome people.
Pete: So, anything else that's awesome about
Tapad that we missed that you want to talk
about?
Dag: I think we've covered a lot.
I'm sure we have missed a lot.
I think the key takeaway here is the team
we're building and the fun we're having.
Everybody's pulling in the same direction.
Nobody is slacking.
Doesn't mean we're working people twenty-four/seven
here.
Actually, that's one of my, one of my principles
is actually that I want people to have a sustained
pace all along.
We don't burn the midnight oil every time.
We expect people to pull through if we're
in a tough spot, but now, the team is also
outside engineering.
That's important.
Everybody here is pleasant to work with.
Yeah.
Great.
Awesome.
Well.
Thanks for chatting with us.
This has been really great.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I appreciate it.